since
okay
now remember
remember that that means you know how
you know what they say about hot mics i
uh i thought i'd turned it off but i i
wasn't real successful
okay
i'd like to call the fiscal committee
meeting to order
and uh the first order of business is
acceptance of the meeting
of june 17th 2022.
do i have a motion
thank you move the minutes
thank you uh senator d'alessandro do i
have a second
second
okay uh
senator
yeah
i'm
okay daniels
thank you
all those in favor
please say i i opposed
all right that's done
okay
um
the following items are going to come
off the consent calendar
do you want to mention the old business
that we're not thinking about
yeah
it's fine it's just
uh fis
22 244
fis22255
fis22256
fs2247
fis22250
fis-22263
are there any other items to come off
seeing none
uh could i have a motion to accept the
okay okay i'm gonna call the rule
oh
yes you may call the roll okay
this is on the consent calendar
uh representative enriquez
representative leishman
representative petry yes representative
walner
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger uh yes i'm sure the vote is
10-0 thank you vote is 10-0
items are approved
uh you don't all have to leave you know
[Laughter]
this is probably one of the most
exciting things you could do on a friday
morning
hey i took a shower and b i brush my
teeth
good morning nathan white dhhs cfo
good morning trish tilly director of
public health
good morning
i'm glad you didn't leave so thank you
okay uh senator daniels i believe you
have some questions to start with yes
thank you thank you madam chair
um noticed in in the explanation it
talked about that
uh
that some money didn't you didn't get
some money that you thought you were
going to get us something and can you
explain a little bit about that in the
process on how we ended up where we are
sure
so during during the senate phase of the
budget the department had requested to
remove 1.6 million dollars in federal
funds from each year at the time there
were a number of unknowns relative to
the federal funds we we didn't know
whether the federal dollars would be
going directly to some of the family
planning centers
and at that point in time
director tilly can speak better to this
but at that point in time there are also
challenges relative to the title 10
rules um whereas many of the uh the
family planning
contractors uh they were not willing to
take those funds at that time i don't
know if you want to elaborate on that
yes so thank you very much for that so
again uh early in in that senate phase
there was some conversation about um
whether we were going to both be able to
expend those funds or if those funds
were going to go directly to the vendors
one of the miscommunications that
happened that time was around this
notion of funds going directly to from
the federal government directly to a
vendor that is the case for one agency
but the rest of the agencies that we
contract with get our funds uh the
department really put them out into
contracts so um we knew that when this
happened um that we would likely need to
have to come back to fiscal to remedy
this we knew we would also be getting a
new award
so that that's part of the the confusion
that happened back in the budgeting
process this this item here today simply
allows us to accept new funding that's
been made available to us so that we can
disperse it into the community
okay and this new funding is on top of
the funding that you had through the
budget
um i'll let you answer that part of that
yes we're asking to add add this federal
grant award to the budget again an error
was made during the the senate phase
where we requested that the 1.6 million
be taken out historically um those funds
have always been budgeted through the
budget process um in recent memory i i
can't recall or nor was i able to
identify any time at which those funds
had been taken out so this is really to
to add the the carryforward grant funds
allow us to spend those funds um and and
the new grant award uh in a normal year
this would have just been included in
hb1 and it already would have been
budgeted but again because an error was
made at that time during the senate
phase given the many unknowns uh we had
requests that it be taken out
and the only thing i'll add on that from
a programmatic side was
again we're in a new award period with
our federal funder so we had federal
funds in the beginning for state fiscal
year 22.
those funds have now all been either
expended or returned to the federal
government we have a new award that was
awarded to us in april
2022 and so that's what we're accepting
here is that new award that was awarded
to us for a new five-year cooperative
period okay so so how did we how did we
make it through
without these funds
in in the last round sure thank you so
part of the um
within our appropriation uh in the past
fiscal year even early back in the
fiscal year some of our agencies were
not
expending or didn't want to accept
added some federal funds uh i believe in
december executive council so some of
those federal funds were put into
contract we knew that we would need to
amend those contracts this spring when
we got a new award so we just simply
didn't spend down all of those federal
dollars we anticipate spending down this
okay
and with uh
with title 10 did the change of the
administration and washington did that
in effect anyway new hampshire's
i'll answer that this way so yes there
was a change in the federal
administration
under the previous administration there
were some rules attached to the title 10
funds that made some of our
historical
partners in the community either
ineligible and then other entities did
not choose to participate in title 10
because of some of the rules that were a
part of the title 10 program back under
the previous administration
um in the fall of last year november
some those rules changed and our
partners in the community are
willing to participate in the title 10
program now
okay i uh how many how many agencies
or organizations would be getting this
money that's a great question
i can tell you that we currently have
four community health centers so places
like amiskegh health in manchester coast
family health up in berlin um the
belmont merrimack cap in the laconia
area and lamprey i believe yep lamprey
down in the nashua area those are our
current grantees going to governor and
council to add additional funds um to uh
because that's in procurement i can't
tell you who's in that bucket um so when
those go to executive council we will be
adding funds to agencies that have
responded to an rfp that was back in the
fall
okay and one final question
uh
under class 102 it indicates that the
funds will be used to contract with
vendors to provide services required by
title 10 program
but we don't have any kind of a list as
to what those
things are other than some ambiguous
terms that
could pick up many different things
sure i i can tell you um what isn't
funded and then i can tell you what is
funded so abortion services are not
funded through title 10 services no
state nor general funds are allowed to
be used for abortion related services so
i'll put that over to the side what is
funded is access to comprehensive
reproductive health care and that
includes access to contraception it
includes cancer screening cervical
cancer screenings and other screenings
it includes screening for sexually
transmitted infections and treatment for
those sexually transmitted infections it
includes other sort of education for
even things like abstinence safer sex
those are the pieces that are included
within title 10.
no okay
uh could i have a motion i would move
the item thank you senator d'allesandro
okay
mike on
uh this is for 244
represents
representative leishman yes
representative petry representative
walner
senator daniels no
senator morse yes
senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is nine to one
thank you the vote being nine to one
we now turn to fis-22255
department of military affairs
good morning ma'am committee members for
the record major general david mikulitis
the adjutant general new hampshire
national guard
and with me to here today is a colonel
rich albertman the director of our
and the uniform of the day is um
fatigues yes we call it ocp
was it operational camouflage pattern
yeah whatever it is
yeah those those came out after uh i
left the service so
i don't have a pair of those in my
closet but
so i'm sorry
well welcome and uh
senator daniels did you have a question
the the explanation on this seems like
it should be something that fits more in
the department of education than when
veterans affairs you know when we're
talking about uh increasing the
knowledge and the skills of stem
so i was wondering if you could just
help me make that connection
with the military
uh yes sir so uh you're referring to on
what's called star base
it's a department of defense funded
program for youth-based initiatives
and so the funding comes through dod
department of defense
we were the ones who took the initiative
to apply for the application and to
compete nationally for this program that
increases based training for fifth grade
students
in local schools
so once it's established we'll
collaborate with department of education
to ensure whether the curriculum
is learned everywhere or part of the
education-based system that gets credit
for in the school system but because
okay and i i think i kind of understand
all that i just i don't see the
connection i mean you you're helping out
a fifth grader but you know if you were
saying this is going to help us
recruit
something later i i just i i can't find
that connection
there are certain youth-based programs
that the department of defense funds for
example there's something called youth
challenge so for underprivileged kids
who are who are struggling to get
through a high school degree certain
states run what's called the youth uh
youth challenge program where sort of
like a one-year military type boot camp
where the disadvantaged kids who might
not get a high school degree come and
just run like a one year boot camp to
get these kids to get a ged
this is a sim this is a separate but
program uh
developed for a youth so
a lot of our technology in the air force
the air national guard at pease and some
of our high-tech stuff in the army guard
here our highmars rocket systems require
like a technical base competency of
which today's youth doesn't have
so they do their asvab test to try to
take that
initial enlistment um
test
um the scores aren't there
so this is just an initiative to try to
promote stem based topics in schools
they won't say but indirectly it exposes
the youth to the military so by us
hosting it in pembroke
um it'll allow kids to come and see
military personnel
might put the connection you know if we
have a helicopter there or something
like that where they see this sort of um
correlation between getting a stem type
education and how it correlates to a
sort of military profession
representative petrie uh thank you madam
chair and thank you for being here
uh i'm surprised that you haven't you
don't work more with the civil air
patrol because they do a lot of this uh
training you know uh through through
their program
and
obviously the civil air patrol auxiliary
air force so
if you would
uh sir we do so we sort of partnered
with civil air patrol on abc cadets and
it's boyce call scouts bsa
to support them so for example civilian
patrol and sea cadets use our concrete
armory to host their monthly meetings
and so we typically open up our armories
for no cost to any youth-based program
if they need facilities to be used
right you know is there more
coordination with what they do you know
as far as the programs
uh
yes to the extent that we will typically
meet with their leadership on an annual
basis to see what synergy can be
provided so they will use our facilities
for their like lack of a better term
summer camp so they will go up to
stratford new hampshire where our
training facility is and stay overnight
or for the weekend and use some of our
our training facilities there very good
thank you okay
are there any uh
senator d'alessandro oh thank you madam
chair general great to see you uh thanks
for coming
i'd like to know how you identify
students that are at that are at risk
what what's
who do you how do you correlate this
with the education department because
some of these kids may fall into the
category that needs special education
and things of that nature but if you're
going to approve skills for students at
risk in the fifth grade
that's a that's a fairly uh significant
task and this isn't this isn't enough
money in my opinion to do that
so how is it done
so sir
what we did was we reached out to
department of education and after that
we went to the manchester and
londonderry school districts and talked
to their superintendents and we just and
we described the program to them they
were all in unfortunately both districts
their superintendents have moved on so
we got to start a new from those two
schools
but
but they identified the lack of that
stem based and what typically happens
and it varies slightly from state to
state is
for example a fifth grade student would
get on his school bus come to pembroke
and for one day for five days for five
weeks so one day a week for five weeks
show up
to sort of a
stem computer digital classroom
that this will fund both the classroom
material and the teachers
to then just teach these kids almost
sort of like an extracurricular activity
to try to enlighten them and say hey
look this is what you can do
um in that type of environment
one further question so you have to
reach out to the school district
you you create some kind of a
rapprochement with the school district
the school district identifies students
places them
uh in this program
who does the follow-up
um
it will be the
the contracted educators through this
initiative
that will then have to measure the
metrics to prove that like it's it's
improving their scores
thank you chair
thank you general nice to see you again
a manchester memorial high school
graduate
west point graduate distinguished greek
so i would like this program in uh
conway
i i think it's it's it sounds like a
great program
but i think that the focus
on
getting to a school district and doing
some kind of an arrangement with them
and
that's going to be interesting how that
happens right
okay are there any further questions
i would move the item thank you very
much do i have a second
second by senator daniels
this is on 2 55.
hamrick votes yes
representative leishman yes
representative petry yes
walnut yeah
senator daniels yes senator morris
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair the vote is 10-0
thank you the vote being 10 to 0
fis 22 255 passes
from the department of military affairs
did someone have a question
representative rosenwald thank you thank
you madam chair um i have two questions
actually but i don't know if the
department might not be better able to
assist in the answers
the health and human services yeah if
they maybe could
join
good morning lori shibanet commissioner
of health and human services
thank you okay thank you
um
i noticed in the narrative that
they're not specific performance
measures
for
the effectiveness of this proposed
program
but
there's a lot of interest in the
legislature in
in making sure that our substance use
disorder
prevention and treatment programs have
have quantitative measurable
outcomes and we have another item later
from the department of safety about the
no safe experiences
they have two really
i think spot on
performance measures one is the
reduction in the number of drug overdose
deaths in young people and the second
one is the reduction in percentage of
youth use of non-prescribed drugs
and so my question is
what
kind of performance measures
is this program going to have the
narrative points towards it may reduce
stressors
which might reduce binge drinking so we
we're not going to just look at stress
reduction are we we're going to actually
look at
did the gym memberships and the fitness
equipment lead to a reduction
in substance use
and can you get that in a year
so ma'am i'm going to try first i'm
going to pass it on to colonel olbermann
our wellness director so i'll give you
context uh first of all so i said on the
the joint military task force one of a
task force for the governing commission
and alcohol and other drugs and we
advocate for service members families in
the veteran community typically a
majority our advocacy is for veterans
because of the size of the population
within new hampshire
however national guard bureau did a
study of the health of the force for the
army national guard for the 54 states
and territory
in 2019 we ranked 45th in a bad way for
the health of our fours
and the biggest
discrepancy was uh
alcohol misuse that apparently affects
7.9 percent of our force
and then so what we did was this
initiative will hopefully get after that
so i think big broad speaking the annual
performance metric would hopefully be
the decline of substance misuse amongst
our fours
that's the broad and then
to thank you sir
so that's one part of it the other thing
which is also difficult is
this money is not just for the new
hampshire national guard i have to be
very clear about that this money is from
the state of new hampshire for all
service men and women serving in the
state of new hampshire because of that i
don't have access to their metrics
so that's where we're consulting to do
questionnaire support
from a professional
statistician to go ahead and write the
proper questions to get after what
you're asking for is how are we
measuring the decline of substance use
and so that will be contracted out to
that specialist build that and as part
of the reimbursement process they will
have to answer these questions so we can
collect the data from all service
members and have that piece of it
internally what the adjunct general just
stated we have unit risk inventories
that we get an annual basis that we can
show for the new hampshire army national
guard at least whether this has caused a
decrease in their use and that will be
also reported but because it's for all
service members i don't have a tool that
i could
get after what you're looking for
without doing that question there but i
think you did answer
that you're going to look at the
end result not just
did it reduce the stressors oh
absolutely absolutely and i think
that's good my second question has to do
with
the funding more
um
as as you prob i hope know the
governor's commission funding
is currently entirely directed towards
the medicaid program
not
other contracts those contracts have
been backfilled by a five-year agreement
with the hospitals
that runs out i think in another year
what is
the plan for future funding
and maybe commissioner shippenhead
wants to take this is this a one-time
expectation or do you think we're going
to look at
ongoing funding
after that agreement with the hospitals
runs out i think that you know i'll
speak directly to the hospital's
contribution
for the for the governor's commission i
do expect
that we will enter into negotiations to
continue that contribution moving
forward as for this specific agreement
i'm gonna have to let the the general
speak to that because i wasn't part of
those conversations thank you
so ma'am i believe it's a three-year
pilot program
so what we plan on doing is look after
the doubt after three years and seeing
did it work
um
and then
from that point forward then decide if
is that the sort of number one priority
for our service members you know for
example another um another issue we have
is child care
so it's another priority for us but
we're trying
we're trying to get the department of
defense fund a pilot program for that so
it's almost uh three years from now
we'll sort of review this data say is it
our number one issue for service members
to try to reduce substance misuse and
retain them in our force
um
so
final question then if i could so if
you're planning a three-year program but
we have maybe
one or maybe two years
of hospital backfill funding
would you fund the third year or maybe
the second and third year from within
your department's current budget or
would you end this program
so if i understand it correctly ma'am
i think it's
we will
utilize this pilot program up to this
dollar amount of uh 500 000
so in the event it's under utilized we
would probably come to you and ask for
an extension
to just use the funds that have been
allocated right now for the length of
time of which the use is needed
thank you thank you madam chair
are there further questions
yes represent or senator daniels thank
you uh it's been stated that this is the
purpose of this is to
lower substance misuse
we have numerous programs out there
through hhs now
that that deal with that um
and and
to my knowledge they haven't been overly
successful
because we continue to pull more and
why aren't we just using those
programs i mean why why why it seems
like we're getting the military which
should be
more more the defense of the state of
the country uh involved in the these
uh so sir i think an ancillary benefit
to this program is the fact that we it
will also work as a retention tool
so i i tell people all the time there's
no line at our door right this is the
worst recruiting year since the end of
the volunteer draft in 1973. and so the
problem is no one's joining so how do we
retain our soldiers what they have a
substance misuse issue
it's a it's a physical fitness issue
the army just rolled out a new fitness
test called the army combat fitness test
um it's the crossfit games right there's
six events and when 75 percent of your
force is part time and you only see them
two days a month how do you keep them in
shape so they can pass that test and
retain them in your force
so i mean it's primarily to get after
the health of the force but that
ancillary benefit is the fact that if
they're in our force we have to figure
out how to retain them
and it and then we only have two
facilities that have 24 7 gym access
it's concord nsrp national guard bays so
if i'm a part-time soldier in keene
where does he work out or train or
exercise other than those two days a
month where he doesn't have in this
facility so we replicated this state uh
help the state employee sort of uh
anthem blue cross blue shield sort of uh
concept of trying to get reduced gym
membership and sort of buying physical
fitness equipment for their home
in order to hopefully drive
substance misuse down
fitness up and retain a quality force
that we can help the our state in our
nation
so a few years ago i was in the national
guard
we didn't have any kind of this program
how how did we ever make it through
uh uh
i mean
i i think i heard you say that we were
in uh like 45th in health now yes have
you got any kind of historical thing to
show where we were in the last 10 years
they published an annual annual report
so we have the la we have 2019 and 2020
with us i can look back
so in 2019 we're 45th
in a bad way and in 2020 we're 37th
okay i just just just curious because
historically we we didn't have to have
this five hundred thousand dollar
program
to stay to stay in shape but then
what what what has changed i mean
today's youth has difficulty handling
stress
so whether it's substance misuse
suicides or any other stressor to the
today's youth
we have significantly more uh
psychological health directors and staff
to ensure the the health of our force
the fitness test has changed it used to
be push-up sit-ups two-mile run
now it's a deadlift it's a shuttle run
it's a throwing a ball and it's like
everything is more complex or more
demanding
and i would argue that our deployment
cycle has increased
so we just got off uh two years of
covered response we've had over 800
soldiers and airmen activated um we are
in the process of deploying another 450
soldiers out the door in the next 12
months
and so
the pace of our our our op temple
operational temple of what we're doing
has not like subsided and i think when
you look at the
the lack of uh
the ability of our youth to handle
stress
the smaller size of our force and the
operational demands of which we're
placing upon them is creating this
perfect storm
okay one final question this may be more
for the commissioner if this if this
program is successful
where others in hhs may not be as
successful can we expect that there will
be programs that will be dropped within
dhhs
anytime we have duplicate programs that
target the same demographic or the same
audience if we find one of those
programs is more successful than the
other then obviously we would shift
funding towards the program that has
shown to be more successful that is why
we measure our success in all of our
programs thank you
are there further questions
seeing none could i have a motion please
i move the item thank you senator
d'alessandro second
second by representative petry
roll call 256.
enrique voces
representative leishman yes
representative petry yes representative
walner
representing senator daniels yes senator
morse
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes madam chair the vote is 10
to nothing
the vote on fis
22 256 is 10 to zero it passes
we now turn to
fis 22 247
from the department of business and
whoops you need to push the button
good morning my name is mark liberty i
am the broadband project manager at the
new hampshire department of business and
economic affairs happy to answer any
questions or go over this program as you
like okay thank you
uh representative leishman i see that
your mic is on so you must have a
question
i have a few madam chair though okay
just continue with your questions uh
thanks mark for appearing today
so uh
you responded to a couple of questions
we had prior to the meeting and mr shea
was kind enough to get them to us your
answers and
one of the documents you suggested that
we look at was the state of new
hampshire capital projects fund program
plan for broadband contracts
so reading quickly through the document
i see there's a requirement for mapping
i think about eight hundred thousand
dollars in the request that you have
before us today
has any of that mapping been done to
identify
those areas of the state that are really
suffering i think it said thirty
thousand homes or households don't have
access to broadband that's exactly what
we're doing i think when we started this
it was clear there was no real mechanism
to determine what the unserved and
underserved are particularly with the
new
speed i know that in question three um
the federal gov federal government is
going to be requiring um either 100 100
speeds which is upload and download
speeds or 100 upload 20
100 download 20 upload with scalability
to those speeds there's no mapping out
there at the federal or state level that
show that so when we were working on
this we thought it was important to
develop mapping and to put use some of
our administrative funds that we have
with that purpose we thought that was
going to be a benefit for this program
and moving forward
another question if i could have i'm
now it says here that there's going to
be like one contractor selected to
service the whole state am i reading
that correctly i'm just curious for this
part of the entire contract yes um as
this is there's a this is 40 of the
money that we've received from the fed
what we're going to receive from the
federal government we were approved for
122 million
the other approximately 65 to 70 million
dollars is going to be in the broadband
matching grant initiative that was
improved by the legislature last year in
sb 85 and we had to
get it amended this year in senate bill
445 so the majority of the funds that
come from this grant will be through
that broadband matching grant which is
going to be a municipality based program
so isps and towns will work together to
address those and that will be open to
all providers we wanted to move forward
with this other portion of it because as
we were starting to go through this
process we were seeing things like
inflation go up gas prices supply chain
and we felt that
as fast as we could move forward as
compared to other states we felt like it
would give us a better opportunity to
get those supplies and get
the broadband built on happening before
we had all the states working at the
same time because remember there's also
the infrastructure bill that's going to
have at least 100 million dollars and
for other states much much more
so they're all going to be working at
the same time to be doing build out so
we felt it was important to try to get a
jump on that and we felt that was the
best mechanism to do that so forty
percent of those funds will be through
the rfp processes which is currently
out there now with a remaining majority
of the funds in a very targeted
one-on-one community one isp or
however we however that works so that's
how we're going to move forward with
that and just one further if i could
have been i'm sure thanks
so now
what guarantees are you going to have
that these rates now you got a private
company using public funds to develop
better infrastructure for broadband
i see there was like a 30 credit per
month that would be given out
which doesn't seem significant when most
bills are far higher than that those
that can't afford broadband period so
what guarantees is the state going to do
to make sure the prices are reasonable
and i know that thirty dollars is
federally set i understand yep that's
the federal program used to be 50 and
then in the revised arpa bill they
changed it to change the program made it
to 30.
however i they also are going to have
some providers are also going to offer
lower tiers low-cost tiers that will
some of them will start as low as 30 so
theoretically
if you meet certain qualifications you
wouldn't pay anything but that's a
federal program
those are questions that we're going to
be asking to not only to the provider
who would get the uh who would be the
applicant for this rp
also for bmgis and we're going to ask
those questions are you participating in
this program are you going to be
participating in the low-cost tier
program we are going to be asking a lot
of questions on that
at least in bmgi and not in this program
per se
we can't mandate certain prices that's
in the state law so we can't say you can
do a price here but at this community
you have to have a different price we
can't mandate that but we can have a
conversation what are your pricing
what's your plan and we can
we can discuss that and then later on in
infrastructure there's going to be
mechanisms for areas that are considered
high costs and we're still trying to
work through that that's down the line
in probably 2023 and there may be some
mechanisms there to address more of the
of the affordability issues there as
well so there are a lot of areas that
we're going to be looking into to make
sure that those that that there's
affordability built into all of this
thanks thanks madam chair
i i do have one
several years ago
there were broadband studies in the
north country in particular
and the major problem up there was
called the last mile
are we is this broadband
thing
going to go the last mile
yes and that's the preference of
the programs we're working with so every
dollar that we're doing all all 122
minus the administrative costs will go
towards last mile build out correct okay
because that's that's the real problem
not
you know
not um
having six
isps in your town so
pardon
me
okay thank you
i'm sorry
do i have a second i'll second it thank
you senator d'alessandro
will the clerk please call the roll
roll on 247.
henrik voces representative leashman yes
representative petrie yes representative
walner
senator daniels yes senator morris
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umbrer yes
man i'm sure the vote is ten to zero
thank you with a vote of ten to zero fis
22 for 247 passes
we now thank you
thank you
we now turn to fis-250
from the department of
good morning madam chair and members of
the board for the record i'm bob scott
commissioner for the department of
environmental services i have with me
brandon kernan who is the head of our
drinking water section uh a very busy
section of lake uh to answer any of your
questions so uh
madam chair i can give a brief
explanation if you'd like or we can just
go right to questions um we're here at
your disposal okay let's see what we
if i could i would say we have a lot of
great work going on in the department
i'm very very proud of the group
and i by the way i appreciate the email
i got yesterday
explaining um
water mapping
whatever it's called
i know it has a name
uh for mapping your uh
where your water lines are
and um
so that was that was a good thing and i
appreciate it and i'm sure that
hopefully some of the other folks in
here
uh
got
good news from uh from d.e.s
so
senator morris
okay thank you senator morris moves the
item do i have second by senator
rosenwald
this is on two five zero enrique voce
yes representative leishman yes
representative petry yes representative
walner
senator daniels yes senator morris
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger uh yes
madam chair of the voters 10-0 thank you
the vote being could you hang on just a
second because i forgot to ask a
question but the item passes okay that's
that's not a problem
um
yeah we're we're talk we're talking
about checking lead pipes
this is just in the main water system
or is it the connection between
the
public water or the main water system in
the house
so i'll defer to
uh brandon here but uh it does the the
federal requirements and therefore what
we're trying to help the the systems
with
are including not only the water main
but the the connections that
go to the house okay so is that okay
all right that's that's a good thing
thank you very much and uh we're we're
not doing very well on this one not
representing hamrick well my question is
a little bit just
kind of on this topic but in general uh
i'm the chairman of the planning board
in our town and we're confronting right
now the groundwater remapping of the
town
uh and the aquifer protection zone
come to find out the new federal
mapping
we have a closed dump
that we capped about 10 years ago
it sits right in our aquifer protection
zone
as newly defined
uh should
should there be or is there a program to
do
a pfest testing
for these capped
uh dumps uh representative emrick i have
i'm not sure if it got to
commissioner scott or not but i have
asked at our september meeting
that he come prepared to talk to us
about the pfas problems in local
landfills
i'll look forward to the answer and um
so that because
when i read through
the information that was in here
uh
wells
looked to be in great shape as opposed
to
where we stand on uh on landfills so
we'll be we'll be having that
discussion in um
in september
i look forward to it thank you okay and
hopefully
he can answer any questions we might
have on that so
thank you very much this could be that
could be a long meeting madam check
well that's okay uh obviously i think we
all know that uh
the pfas business is uh
unending and we need to try to get a
handle on it so thank you very much
sorry
okay
we now turn to fis
and we are going to kind of do these in
conjunction
and
good morning chase hageman deputy
director at the governor's office for
so commissioner caswell sent you here by
yourself today huh i'm on my own you're
um
where am i
okay ah
are there any questions on um
okay
uh mike i did have a i did have a
question and uh although you sent an
answer i think it's important that we
all understand this
um
it says in there that uh utility
or that rental assistance
also receives funding for
electricity and
heating
whatever it is correct
and
uh just
speculating that
most of the people that would be
applying for rental assistance
are in the category of
being able to apply for light
and so my my question is
are we messing with the light program
or
do they get both
or what kind of guidance has gone out on
that
uh that's a great question and as you
mentioned madam chair we did provide a
response but for the record um
as we understand it has been described
to us by the department of energy there
is no negative impact on the light
program by the rental assistance program
as in in terms of the reimbursement of
utility costs getting emergency rental
assistance for utilities doesn't pull
someone out of the light program or the
fuel assistance program and there's no
double dipping there's just there are
systems in place that help track who is
getting what so that when one assistance
is provided for a utility the other is
not
okay um
are we still in the phase where
the renter has to apply
yes so as a basis of the program the
renter applies uh that's that's always
been the case okay and so as i looked at
the figures it doesn't appear to me
that
the renters are applying
okay and i don't know whether
the
landlords are just being kind and not
kicking them out
or if
you know exactly where that is
so
in general the the demand for the
program has sustained if not grown over
the last year or so so i'm not i'm not
sure which numbers you're referring to
where it appears that there is a
reduction applications it actually has
sustained if not risen a little bit over
time oh okay okay and is that run
through cap
yes so um gopher uh basically
sends money to new hampshire housing
finance authority who works with the
caps to facilitate the program both
rental assistance and utility assistance
okay
thank you uh
senator daniels thank you my
understanding is that it's the the
renter that applies
for it and that uh any
assistance is is sent to the renter
that's incorrect though the assistance
goes directly to the landlord and the
utility company to to pay the rent or
the utility bill um in limited
circumstances the renter would
potentially receive the money if the
landlord is not particularly
agreeable in terms of interacting with
the program
are there are there any programs
possibly under cap or whatever that
the money is sent to
the renter because i'm i'm dealing with
a constituent who
uh
has somebody that had been renting but
now they're not paying their rent
but they can't kick them out
and that they had they had applied for
money
but the landlord's not seeing any of it
on a case-by-case basis i'm hap we're
happy to help work with a landlord or a
tenant to resolve any particular issues
and we often do that so cases will come
into us with a particular issue or
challenge to address and we work with
new hampshire housing finance to see if
there's a remedy so i'd be a little
resident to
reticent to speak to a specific
situation without getting more detail on
the applicant in the landlord situation
just to answer your question sorry um
i i would have to get additional
information from the caps on any
programs they have where money is sent
directly to the tenant
i don't believe that is the case
by and large in era i would imagine
you'll have a call from senator daniels
i imagine i will
[Laughter]
uh
representative leishman
thank you madam chair and thanks for
being here today
so i think it was after the fact but
the lba did provide us with a copy of
the governor's office of emergency
relief and recovery
contribution i guess if you will to help
with rental assistance for utilities and
internet and so forth of ninety three
hundred dollars is that per year or for
six months or it would be over the la
excuse me over the life of the program
uh based on households that are
receiving the benefits then that spans
all the types of services including
rental assistance under era under the
rental assistance program um households
are able to receive funding
at this point under the era 2 program
which we'll get to in the next item
as as far out or as
in total 18 months they can only ask for
three prospective months at a time
however but over the life of the program
they could receive as much as 18 months
in support
okay and just one further question
certainly i could madam chair thanks
so at our pre-fiscal meeting uh i have
to give credit where i guess it's due
representative edwards raised an
interesting point i thought that by
providing rental assistance we're
actually creating a problem by forcing
rents up perhaps
when if you didn't provide that
assistance it would keep rents lower is
there
is that a supported theory or is makes i
i haven't specifically explored that in
terms of data that might
answer that particular question there
are limitations on what level of income
a household can have to even get into
the program so
in terms of the level of rents being
driven up uh
i i would be hesitant to speculate but
um you know
i'm sure there's data out there that can
be analyzed over time to see if that is
the case okay thanks and thanks madam
chair are there any further questions
okay
uh are there any questions on
22-264 separately
i
obviously this is just an extension of
okay
seeing no additional questions
i'll take a motion on fis 22 263. move
uh representative leishman and senator
d'alessandro
oh it's on 263 eric votes yes
representative leishman yes
representative petry yes representative
walner
senator daniels yes senator morris yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger uh yes madam chair the vote is
ten to zero
vote being ten to zero fis-22 263 passes
could i have a motion please on
fis-22260
move the item thank you senator
d'alessandro
so we'll call in 264 emery votes yes
representative leishman yes
representative petrie yes representative
walner
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes madam chair the vote is ten
to zero the vote being ten to zero fis
i believe four
uh the first one is fis uh 268
uh dealing uh from
the gopher office
uh
requesting
[Music]
seven plus million
for uh sud related programming services
and project investments
are there any questions on this
uh rep senator
thank you yes
rosenwald thank you
um
there are
two parts of it that equals about 12
million dollars for
additional beds
um what are you talking about thank you
for the question sandra and just and
chase hageman deputy director at gopher
again
um just to clarify senator the the two
parts that refer to um increasing bed
capacity i think only total seven
million um the proposed budgets for
those are sorry yeah so you just wanted
to be clear there um
the the short answer is it depends
because we're still working with dhhs
and the governor's council on
alcohol and other drugs to finalize the
program itself which will become
publicly known posted on gopher's
webpage excuse me with all the
guidelines necessary for that
the purpose of the detox bed program
however is to expand uh bed capacity at
various tiers of
detox needs and there are i think four
tiers if i remember correctly this
program would focus on the top tier and
there are a little over 60 beds in the
state right now
and the idea obviously would be to
increase those number of beds and
we have some insight that there are
projects being explored that could
increase that significantly but i don't
know the exact number off the top of my
head it would in part depend on the
construct of the program
thank you well how did you arrive at the
seven million dollars then
if
if it's not by the number of beds we
wanted so the the number is based off of
what would be the purpose of the program
which is capital improvements and
investments
again
we've heard from
other facilities and potential
facilities coming online that
could have
capital needs costs that you know range
from a couple hundred thousand to a
couple million
so we wanted to leave room
in the program
to
provide sufficient awards based on what
becomes the eligibility and requirements
of it
if you notice in the item itself
we did request a little bit of
flexibility on what ultimately becomes
the final funding amount for some of
these programs because as we go on to
finalize what we anticipate being the
need the number may need to change but
it certainly wouldn't go beyond the
authorized amount
requested overall in the item
one final thank you and will these both
of these parts
um be available to the medicaid program
yes the purpose um especially on the
detox side is to make sure that these
are beds that are available for medicaid
users thank you
are there any further questions
i do have a question yes i i'm not
opposed to the program but uh
where are we going to get the people
to uh
work in these facilities since we are
right now we are
you know
we have nursing homes and hospitals that
can't go to their full bed capacity
because they don't have the um
staff to take care of it it's always a
great question madam chair and it's
usually always the same answer it
depends on the you know the entity
coming forward and applying and them
having sufficient staff to run the
program they're proposing
as with all arpa dollars if for some
reason this this um program is
underutilized those funds would come
back for reallocation for other purposes
so the money would not go unused it
would eventually be used for something
but uh the whole state is is
experiencing staffing issues including
the state itself so it's a tough it's
always the question it's always a tough
one to answer okay
i don't have any problem with the
program i just i don't want to have this
great program out there and
the beds go empty so we need to make
sure that when you're asking them that
they uh tell you how they're going to
man it
and if if i may a woman whatever i just
wanted to point out um the late items
that came through uh for for vote today
are all interconnected relative to sud
um initiatives and programs so i just
didn't want to leave any of the other
agencies that are coming to the table
late out to dry
um they're all connected okay
uh could i have a motion please on fis
22 268
thank you uh senator d'alessandro ii
clerk please call the roll roll call on
268 emrick votes yes representative
leishman yes representative petry
representative walner
senator daniels yes sir morse yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umbrover yes madam chair
of the voters ten to zero the vote being
10 to zero fis 22 268 passes thank you
we now turn to fis
22 269
from the department of
health and human services
and this is to just
primarily to purchase and distribute
good morning so good morning for the
record i am katya foxx i'm the director
of the division for behavioral health
good morning nathan white cfo dhhs
thank you
are there any questions
from
anyone yes i have
go senator daniel thank you madam chair
um
i'd like to see some sort of
documentation on the success
we have had i mean we continue to to
provide funds for naloxone but
we don't never seem to see any reports
on
you know whether the numbers are going
down whether they're going up how the
money's being spent where it's being
spent or anything like that i mean maybe
you could shed some light on that
so thank you and um in one of the pre uh
fiscal questions this question did come
up and we cited the research um we do
have uh dr ballard here who
has looked extensively into the
effectiveness of
the different strategies for addressing
most importantly the opioid
epidemic
so he's available here to perhaps answer
your questions and we can also provide
the research that we cited in that
response okay why don't you ask them to
good morning for the record my name is
jonathan ballard to work as the chief
medical officer for department of health
and human services
there's been extensive research on the
approach to solving improving upon the
opioid overdose problem
substance use disorder in general
as you're aware new hampshire is good
could you move your mic a little closer
thank you
new hampshire had a significant
significant escalation of opioid
overdose deaths really starting in about
2014 and we hit our high in 2017
and so
that led forth you know a very large
multi-pronged effort to combat substance
use disorder
and reduce opioid overdose deaths
naloxone being one potential or once
part of that overall package
since 2017 opioid overdose deaths in new
hampshire have declined year over year
and we're the only state in the country
to has had year-over-year declines of
opioid overdose deaths in fact during
the pandemic
when all others most all other states
all the except for states
had opioid overdose deaths significantly
increase including our neighbors in
vermont had very high year-over-year
increases new hampshire did not
so there's been studies researchers who
have looked at this
in the medical journal called public
health reports it's the surgeon
general's
medical journal
an article came out last year that
looked at why did new hampshire and the
three other states have a different
outcome compared to the rest of the
country when really this is a worldwide
problem of substance use disorder and
opioid overdose deaths
in that report it said specifically that
new hampshire and these other states had
very common
approaches
of why they were so successful it said
that you have to have
broad state policies you have to improve
treatment opportunities you have to
educate prescribers you have to
and they lay out particularly you have
to have broad-based naloxone
distribution
what new hampshire did differently prior
to the opioid the pandemic
was we made a shift in how we got
naloxone out to the public
previously
there's a standing order that i write
that anybody can pick up naloxone the
legislature
allowed us to make that standing order
people can go to a pharmacy to pick it
up but that's not been successful in new
hampshire nor other states across the
country
it has to be directly distributed put
into the hands of bystanders loved ones
to allow for that opioid reversal agent
to be available and work
so that's so when the we created the
doorways program we shifted distribution
of naloxone being from a centralized
state program
out through our partners more local to
the communities where individuals
where the doorways know their local
non-profit agencies the non-profit
agencies and other partners are the ones
now who are giving out naloxone directly
to the potential bystanders for an
opioid overdose death
and
we know naloxone works in the laboratory
method but what i think you're getting
at center daniels is
how do we know it's getting to the right
people and that it's being effective
if we look at our um amr
ambulance companies reports from
manchester and nashua you see last year
a very significant change happened it
used to be most naloxone was being
delivered by the ambulance the truck
when it arrives to uh to us a scene of
an opioid overdose
and now it switched
they were finding that more naloxone was
being arriving
and administered by a bystander compared
to the ambulance so that was a very key
data point we're tracking
about that we're also tracking where the
naloxone is going you know through the
doorways we we keep good records on
where it's happening you know where
which how much is going to
we've embarked this summer on reaching
out and connecting visiting the doorways
um they're telling me that it's being
adequately it's being used but they need
more what's happening with the border
and more fentanyl coming into the
country
has been
in the recent
news over the last few months of some
increase in spikes across the country
with
more um
exposure to fentanyl has required more
naloxone to combat this and that's
partly why this is is really um critical
now that we uh shore up make sure that
that the supply of naloxone as part of
the overall larger pro
program that we have that's been so
successful for new hampshire compared to
other states
um so that i hope that answers your
question thank you follow-up
yes go ahead
do uh would we track
any
have any data to indicate if the
recipients of naloxone are entering a
we do in the fact that they enter into
the doorway system so when the doorway
when they come through the doorways
we
do an intake process and we were making
those referrals warm handoffs care
coordination trying to close the loop
you know
substance use disorder though is a you
know remitting relapsing disease
uh and so we see it's all parts of
recovery that some some people
will not
um
uh
you know would not successfully maintain
their sobriety of the of the illness
essentially maintain it in recovery for
treatment and we'll have relapses
ultimately there will be some
individuals who may be revived more than
once but what that does is it allows
that person to still be alive and still
have a chance to to to achieve recovery
through our partners
senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair good morning
i'm glad you brought up manchester and
nashua because while
the statewide opioid deaths may be down
manchester and nashua
are both on track this year to have an
increase of about a third
versus a year ago so something is
something is wrong in our two largest
cities what
improvements is the department going to
make with the doorways
to bring nashua and manchester
down in opioid deaths as the rest of the
thank you senator rosenwald so just
recently i had an opportunity to visit
the doorway there in manchester and see
the good work that's being done and
they're really um you know doubling down
on um sharing up the linkages that they
have with community partners
such as farnham and others
to
to get more people transitioned earlier
more timely into these
uh
treatment programs
we're also wanting to make sure that we
have adequate levels of naloxone in
those communities
and then part of it though is beyond the
treatment system part of it is beyond
drug pattern pattern problems as well i
think there's others here as well that
could speak to the nut you know the
non-treatment aspects of it
that may be contributing to that
are there further questions
seeing none could i have a motion on fis
269 i'll move the item thank you senator
d'alessandro
second
thank you senator gray
will the clerk please call the role
we'll call on 269. enrique focus
representative leishman yes
representative petry yes represented
wallner
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes madam chair the vote is 10
to nothing
we now turn to
fis-22270
from the
department of
safety
good morning steve lavoy director of
administration from the department of
safety and with me is lieutenant joe
villars from new hampshire state police
oh so he didn't get the memo on the
uniform of the day huh
okay
sorry
are there any any questions on
it sounded sounds to me like it's going
to be a very good program so
could i please have a motion move the
item thank you uh representative
leitchman do i have a second second
second by senator delazant d'allesandro
will the clerk please call the roll roll
call on two seven zero camerick votes
yes representative leishman yes
representative petrie yes representative
walner
senator daniels yes senator morris yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator alessandro yes representative
umberger uh yes
man i'm sure the vote is ten to zero
the vote being ten to zero fis-22 270
passes
now don't think you're going to get away
with such easy things in the future okay
steve
thank you very much
okay we now turn to
fis
oh it's an information item okay oh
does anybody have any questions on
this item
okay thank you
all right i i'm sorry
tracy
um
turning to the uh
informational items
uh i just want to mention
that
fis 22 257
on state employee health insurance
uh
presentation in september on
how we manage
health insurance for
the employees
and i've already mentioned that on
the concern that i had there was on the
pfas in the landfills
which
represented emeric also brought up
okay
so we now
[Music]
this is that big book that that you all
received
good morning madam chair
members of the committee for the record
uh steve smith director of audits for
the lba
um these two uh reports the single audit
report the big one and then the small uh
management letter our product of uh kpmg
we retain them from the single audit and
the management letter is a byproduct of
both the
state act for audit as well as the
single audit
joining us from kpmg is barack romano
the partner
on the engagement and with him is
brienne orisko
senior manager
and then from department of
administrative services is commissioner
house and dana
to call our comptroller so i believe
dana has a couple of opening remarks and
then she'll
good morning dana call state comptroller
my office is responsible for working
with both teams to get this document put
out for you
we are a little later in the cycle than
normal for this is an fy21
document and we're closing fy22 right
now as we speak in fact today so um we
are
we were allowed the last two years due
to the covid pandemic we were allowed a
little extra time to get the single
audit work done
typically it is out
so after the fiscal year closes we
usually have nine months to get it out
so it's usually the following march
they provided an extension all the way
out excuse me until this september
however we stru we were striving to get
it done by june 30th so that was that
was our goal and similar to the last
year
so you have a handout there are a couple
little tweaks on the finding numbers we
put the handout together a few weeks
before we had sort of finalized the
categories of findings but in general
the total findings are
portrayed for you as a 36 35 36 that's
about where we're at for
in total for material weaknesses and
significant deficiencies
and
based on i gave you sort of the total
federal dollars that are subject to
audit
not everything gets audited every year
there's a cycle for determining and the
auditors will let you know how how they
do that but
basically the federal funds have
as you are aware continued to climb uh
we were typically for year after year
after year about 2.3 billion we went to
3.6 billion and now 4.3 billion
soon to be another billion
we're counting billions now which is a
little scary um
this what we had through fiscal 21
doesn't reflect any arpa funds
so what we reflect through fiscal 21
was essentially the cares act money that
came the coronavirus relief fund the
first billion
and then
obviously a lot of programs like
education and medicaid and others got
other funding sources in addition to the
coronavirus relief fund that was
administered through the gopher office
so really it's um you're seeing between
this year
uh
between fiscal 21 and fiscal 22 what
we'll present to you
a year from now is sort of the wrap up
of the first billion the coronavirus the
first 1.25 billion which is the
chronobytes relief fund and then
subsequent to that you'll start to see
the arpa funding coming through these
reports so there's a there's a big delay
in terms of
when something is provided to the state
when we've allocated it to
whomever is going to spend it and then
when it actually gets spent so just keep
that in mind but um the good news is
even with the extensive additional
federal funding our our audit findings
we believe are manageable
similar themes a lot of it with
compliance findings is a technicality
unlike the act for audit where we have
some level of materiality in terms of
determining whether findings that get
presented to you how significant they
are
compliance findings are reported
essentially regardless so it tends to be
a higher number of findings but we look
at sort of the material weaknesses and
try to keep that in check
so
i guess i want to thank my team in admin
services because um again we've
we're doing this with our existing staff
um and we're hoping you know again to
expand that as the arpa funds come
through because there is a lot of a lot
of audit work that gets done sort of at
the tail end so
but we have it we have it under control
and
the commissioner has anything to add
nope he's here for questions so we'll be
happy to answer questions after kpmg
thank you dana for the record my name is
brock romano i'm the lead auto partner
both on the acfor as well as the single
audit
brianna risco is joining me today she's
one of two senior managers who helped
with the uniform guidance or the audit
of federal awards given given the
complexity of it so what i want to do
this morning is maybe just make a few
brief comments on the telephone book
that's in front of you
and then ask brienne to kind of go into
some
some level of detail
and then
happy to go into more detail
if there's questions that the committee
has so in just in terms of of the
telephone book just just to kind of give
you an idea of the contents uh there's
multiple tabs in here and i just want to
talk briefly about those tabs so there's
a tab
for the financial statements and so that
that section is actually the act for and
that was presented to the fiscal
committee back in in january of this
year
um
the next section is is our reports on
inter uh on compliance and internal
controls there's actually two reports in
there one of them is a report on
internal controls related to the act for
and again that's reproduced here but
that was presented to the committee back
in
in january of this year and then the
other report is a a report on internal
controls on federal programs
uh not an opinion but a report on
internal controls and then we actually
give a compliance uh opinion as soon
assuming we give an audit opinion on
compliance for those largest programs
that we audit and you know brienne will
get into that in a little in a little
more detail as well
uh and then there's a section called the
uh c4 the schedule of expenditures of
federal awards think of that as the
equivalent of a financial statement so
this is where we would list
all of the 300 or so programs
that the state of new hampshire spent
during the year
and
there's a there's a summary page uh that
i'm gonna flip to later on that'll let
you see that visually and maybe a page
or two instead of trying to digest
um uh
uh 27 pages i
and then there's a section on current
year findings so there's 36 total
findings
one of them relates to the act for which
again was presented and reproduced here
and then there's 35
findings relative to your federal awards
again brienne will go into a little bit
more detail on that but just just to
give the committee a sense of of the
contents then the last tab is a section
of of status of prior year findings and
so findings
basically stay in that
section until they're resolved and or
the federal government expresses no
further action usually that happens
after a period of time two or three
years i might just make the general
comment that
when we do our audit when we identify a
finding we're typically well into the
next fiscal year so the life cycle of a
compliance finding typically has two
years so you know don't be alarmed if
you see a finding that maybe you know
spans two audit reports but you might
want to pay attention to findings that
stay on three four
uh that are more chronic and brienne
will will mention a little bit of that
so now if you'll indulge me i'm going to
actually maybe have you flip into a page
or two so just beyond the table of
contents
uh after the um introduction letter
there's uh page number b2 and b3
and so i i point this page out because
this this lets you see in two pages all
in a summary fashion the 4.6 billion
dollars
that new hampshire spent dana had
mentioned it and it's broken out by
something called type a programs which
which are basically your largest
programs state of new hampshire
typically has you know less than 30 of
those largest programs with just a
handful medicaid uh unemployment this
year coronavirus relief fund
you know making up the majority of the
spend
so
rather than go through through 26 pages
of detail this allows you to see
in a quick snapshot kind of you know
what the spending would look like
again uh trying to be high level here if
we want to go into more detail happy to
do it and then the the next
page that i might ask you to flip to
is
is in the tab called current year
findings in question cost
that first page f-1
is uh
for folks of my generation i call this
the cliff notes version of the uniform
guidance report it summarizes on just a
couple of pages
basically the audit results
and so the top of the page is reserved
for the financial statements again
reproduce we've already discussed it
the middle of the page talks about the
federal awards that's kind of what we're
here to talk about
it it lets you know that we identified
some findings that
have material weaknesses again most
severe category of control findings some
findings had significant deficiencies
the the middle category if you will
and then it lists the programs where
we actually
detail out the the programs that had a
qualified opinion
qualified in the sense that there was
some compliance element that they that
wasn't uh materially adhered to think
about allowability think about finance
federal reporting
think about
sub-recipient monitoring those are the
types of compliance areas that we test
and if and if there's a big enough
problem
uh in that area we would qualify so
here's the programs that had a
qualification
the remaining programs we looked at were
unqualified
and then on the next uh page it
on the next page it shows the 18 largest
programs that we looked at
so
that's kind of a real high level of of
what the telephone book has
uh we do want to pull you down into a
little detail i've asked brienne to kind
of prepare some comments about some
things that that might be of interest to
the committee and with that i'd like to
turn over to her and let her walk
thank you bro good morning for the
record my name is brianna risco
as brock mentioned as part of the 2021
uniform guidance audit we focused on 18
of your largest programs
the uniform guidance does not require us
to look at programs every single year
there's some risk assessment guidance
that we're allowed to apply
looking at prior year audit results
dollar spends as well as certain
programs that the office of management
and budget designates as what are called
higher risk programs
so for
2021 omb did designate the medicaid
program as a higher risk program this
program is higher risk every year
by omb they also designated some of the
covid programs as higher risk education
stabilization fund coronavirus relief
fund and the emergency rental assistance
program
were three of those programs that were
designated higher risk that we looked at
as part of the audit
the 18 programs that we focused on
constituted about 3.9 billion of the
total 4.6 billion reported on the cfa or
about 85 percent of your total spend
six of the 18 programs were also audited
as part of the 2020 audit um last year's
audit and were required to be audited
again because of the severity of the
findings identified during 2020
those included medicaid the unemployment
program title one temporary assistance
foster care and opioid
so programs managed across a couple of
the state's different departments
and then one of the programs the
coronavirus relief fund
was also audited as part of 2020 and
re-audited as part of 2021 simply
because it was designated higher risk
there were no findings identified as
part of the 2020 audit
brock and dana both covered this a
little bit
there were a total of 36 findings one
for the act for 35 for the uniform
guidance
16 of the 35 were considered to be
material weaknesses and 19 of them were
considered to be significant
deficiencies
and of the 35 findings that were
reported for 2021 uh seven of them um
were repeated comments of those that
so based on the results of our audit we
issued an opinion on each of the 18
programs that we audited which are
summarized for you on that page f1
for nine of the 18 programs we issued a
qualified or a modified opinion that
included the supplemental nutrition
assistance program snap the unemployment
program the coronavirus relief fund the
emergency rental assistance program the
education stabilization fund the
epidemiology and laboratory capacity
grants program the temporary assistance
program the lie heat program and the
medicaid program
each of these nine programs had findings
that were considered to be material
instances of non-compliance and in some
cases material weaknesses and internal
control
the medicaid program additionally has a
scope limitation noted as part of the
2021 audit which is consistent with the
of the nine programs that we issued a
qualified opinion for three of them also
had qualified opinions as part of the
2020 audit that includes unemployment
tanf and medicaid
and tanf and medicaid have had qualified
opinions for at least the past three
years
the 11 remaining programs
had an unmodified or a clean opinion for
the findings themselves begin on page f7
beginning with finding 2021 0 0 2
0 0 1 relates to the financial
statements and was presented to you
previously
and finally each of the findings that is
included in the report
management is required to provide a
response to the finding which is noted
at the bottom of each of the findings
and they're also required to provide a
corrective action plan to resolve the
matters that are identified
the corrective action plan are they are
included within the report
and then as outlined in our opinion the
state is responsible for preparing a
corrective action plan
and the state's responses and what was
included in those is not subject to our
audit opinion and so we do not express
is there any questions i can answer on
the 2021 audit report
senator daniels thank you how does the
program
earn the designation of high risk
the high-risk programs are designated by
the office of management and budget so
each year when they put out the
compliance supplement they designate
certain programs to be higher risk
typically it includes only the medicaid
program
it's always a high risk program with the
outflow of funding related to covid they
started designating some of those
programs that get a significant amount
of covid dollars as higher risk as well
but that designation um is given solely
by the office of management and budget
okay and just could you elaborate a
it's programs i think where omb has
determined that there's a high risk of
non-compliance with federal regulations
so if you think about the medicaid
program for example there's very complex
eligibility requirements to depend on
are you eligible for medicaid and if you
are which um
benefits span or eligibility program are
you in fact eligible for it's a complex
calculation many things go into it so i
think because of that for one example
omb feels that medicaid is a higher risk
program and feels that there could be a
high risk of non-compliance or misuse of
federal dollars okay thank you and final
question
um
it was mentioned earlier that some of
the some of the times you see after two
or three years that things just drop off
uh is there a reason for that or is that
the federal government decides this
isn't important anymore and we've wasted
our time for two or three years or
i think the answer would be twofold so
in most cases by the time we identify a
finding as part of the audit you're well
into your next
fiscal year
so
by nature of having identified it
halfway through your next fiscal year it
would live likely again on our next
audit report just giving the timing of
when the audit happens
um in the case of things kind of falling
off in some cases federal departments
will write directly to say your
department of health and human services
and say the audit finding that kpmg
noted in their report from x year had to
do with this we feel that you have
provided sufficient documentation since
then to resolve that item and
federal hhs will say we now consider
this finding to be closed
um so in that case we would review that
letter um and make sure that
we agree that that finding is in fact
closed good thank you
are there any further questions uh
represent leishman
thanks madam cheer
is it all right that we venture to the
management letter or are we still on the
phone book
no please they're shaking their head yes
so all right
maybe before we just leave this i just
we threw a lot of stuff at you yeah your
head's probably spinning
let me try to put some of this in
context so i've worked on several
statewide single audits
california new york massachusetts new
hampshire illinois
the results here i would say are middle
of the pack right
there are other states that that have
many more findings more severe findings
lots of question costs
um and there are some states that quite
frankly
have less
findings less qualifications than you do
but but my experience having worked on
on several states
you're kind of middle of the pack uh in
terms of the states that i kind of
mentioned and and so i
uh you hear all these things material
weakness qualifications in your head
must be spinning you know what
what what's happened it is very hard to
run these programs with these levels of
complexity without
some degree of hiccups and and really
what we look for
is the is the adjudication of those
items right are they rolling off
uh and and we've been satisfied both
with the department response
as well as a supervision from das and
the lba that you know new hampshire's
got a very good handle on its federal
program so i i don't want to i don't
want to dwell on the uniform guidance
but i also want to try to put some of
that into context for the members
i apologize if oh happy to go to the
management no problem no problem
whatsoever yes uh
you may
i i have a 30 000 foot question because
i'm i'm a new kid to this committee this
is only my second year so i'm learning
it it seems to me that this audit is
really done for the federal government
correct okay then that that i'm
i'm
got my feet on the ground again because
i was trying to figure out who's
auditing who and why
and it looks like this is our report
through you to the federal government
about how we're handling their funding
they want some
oversight of their spend just like you
want oversight of your spend and that
this product does it for them and just
as a curiosity do they do they fund this
they they
allow the auto costs to be funded uh
oftentimes
um uh the grant dollars are capped and
they would rather use grant dollars for
direct assistance
than um uh put audit costs in front of
programmatic dollars so uh
yes they're allowable but not always
utilized that's a fair statement to dana
and
right
yes but when you approve an item through
this mechanism you'll see an audit fund
set aside uh budget
that's that covers this cost
okay thank you for the most part and i
um i was going to add that the federal
cognizant agencies can audit our
agencies directly as well uh this was
this is meant to be sort of a
comprehensive
look but they'll come in individually
and audit a program on their own as well
and uh those those sort of happen
few and far between but they do happen
so
senator roosevelt thank you madam chair
so my question really is is that
interplay between this audit and the
program
specific audits
so for example recently the three-year
audit of the opioid treatment programs
where we have to pay the federal
government back like almost a million
dollars
is that captured anywhere in
these or is it because it goes back a
few years it's not
it will come up in an audit depending on
the timing so
uh the same types of things that that
federal agency found
if it's one of the programs that kpmg
audits they will likely find similar
findings i guess that's what i would say
there uh that particular one that you
talked about was
okay our are you moving to the
management report or are you still in
the
i'm whenever we're telephone letter the
management letter here okay
all right
so all right go ahead thanks madam chair
and thank you all for being here
so representative edwards had a question
he couldn't be here today so he asked me
to ask the question so on page three
um
down we have recommendations that says
management should reinforce policies and
procedures
there's an implied i guess feeling there
that
there are
policies and procedures but do you folks
go and look at those policies and
procedures that you're recommending that
yeah thank you for that question so the
answer is yes we do we first
we have to audit to something and
normally we audit to the existing
policies or procedures if if there
aren't adequate existing policies and
procedures we would then look to our
best practices across our client base
and so in this particular case for this
particular finding uh the uh the policy
of de-provisioning somebody who is
terminated
uh is when um the uh
uh it department is notified
and
and we compare that against so that's
kind of a passive policy right we wait
to be notified and once we're notified
we will de-provision somebody and we
looked at that whether that's kind of
adequate or maybe they should be more
proactive should they be doing something
uh to try to gather that information as
opposed to waiting for it to come in
and we felt that that policy was their
policy was adequate given the uh the
technology and the and the uh the users
of that talk technology because they
weren't as decentralized so for example
if we were talking about new hampshire
first which would be the statewide
accounting system multiple departments
multiple agencies sitting back and
waiting for uh notification might not be
a best practice for that policy uh
whereas for uh new heights uh even
though it's dealing with a large federal
agency we thought that policy was
adequate so
that's a long answer to a simple
question but hopefully
it addressed the question that you asked
i i think it probably did thank you
thanks madam chair
are there any further questions
do it just up yes go ahead thank you
very thank you very much
just a quick quick comment brock i've
been around for these audits for the
last 24 years
uh it's been it's been a wonderful
experience
i remember the bad audits that we heard
yes the very bad audits that we heard
from your entity vis-a-vis
our state government i think what i've
seen in the last few years
is
a significant
improvement change
high level work on the part of the state
and high level work on the part of of
your organization in terms of the
reports the reports are better they're
more consistent they're well done and
well articulated so i complement you and
i complement the comptroller
you know many years we went without a
comptroller
and that was a
very difficult period for us here in the
state we couldn't fill those jobs
hopefully
we have a lasting comptroller as we
speak but i just want to point out to
the committee
there's been a a dramatic change over
over the years these audits uh uh
from our standpoint i'm much better uh
and i think we're doing a a a much much
better job i can remember deficiencies
that were pointed out in in the at other
times that were very costly to the state
of new hampshire so
kudos to you for the job well done not
i know charlie wanted to mention that if
if we're wrapping up questions we just
want to acknowledge that brock is
rolling off the state audit uh and we're
going to have a new kpmg partner
marie zimmerman is coming back so a
familiar face but we uh it's been a
great working relationship with brock so
we will miss him
kudos to brock no question
i i have to say something because uh so
brock has been involved in the audit or
the single audit for the state since
like the 1940s i think something like
that but for a very long time but um
it's very rare that um
that you enjoy your relationship with
your auditor it's sort of like saying i
have a great proctologist
but um but in this particular case um we
did enjoy it and the state is uh
although there's a there's another great
auditor coming but the state is going to
miss brock and you're going to miss
brock and
and i can't promise senator d'alessandro
that we'll have another italian either
so on behalf of the state of new
hampshire and and all of its people
[Applause]
i i'm embarrassed and uncalled for but i
and though and uh i will just say i i
got more than i gave in the 20 or so
years i've been here it's been a great
pleasure and truly enjoyed uh uh
working with people and
i i ascribe a lot of my technical skills
to
having learned from uh my colleagues at
the lba office right when i was a young
staff person and a young manager so
state of new hampshire has uh
should be very proud of its people and
its departments and it's been my
pleasure to to be here uh wish you best
of luck and
uh maybe you don't get rid of me so easy
maybe i show up at another meeting for
some
unforeseen reason unforeseen reason yeah
might by the way you're welcome any time
thank you thank you very much you know
isn't that what you always say to
auditors you're welcome any time
thank you very much
okay
oh okay
a million thanks okay
all right great
great
uh steve is there anything else
from you
no do we need to accept it yeah
okay
okay go back in here
okay could i have a motion to
accept
the
audit report
place it on file
and distribute it
in the normal
way so moved did i do okay
i think we need a roll call on this
right or not okay all those in favor say
aye aye
okay opposed
okay
seeing none
then
our next meeting
is uh august 10th
at uh
10 o'clock
and um we're going to be discussing um
with the attorney general
the uh
procedures that he has put together
for
ydc
and uh i ex
i expect it will not be a short meeting
but please um
if you have questions uh
make sure that you contact the attorney
general to try to work them out so that
we are not spending eight hours here
okay
well in that case thank you all for
interrupting your summer and uh i'll see
you next month oh chris you have
something i just wanted to clarify that
the august 10th meeting is a special
meeting for that one purpose right that
there is a regularly scheduled meeting
september 9th for regular fiscal
committee business right
i just wanted to get that on the record
oh okay yeah this is very special only
one item
okay
thank you all have a good afternoon and
uh
you